o único deste tema que é no fundo uma
história uma história de um projeto que
inicialmente era muito bia
depois passou para a categoria de sonho
e hoje está na categoria da realidade
como foi dito no ano inicial do meu nome
é joão branco
quando perguntadas inominada têm sempre
problemas em responder é tem uma
resposta é aguardada desde há tempos que
não foi dita por um amigo brasileiro o
diretor de teatro que dizia que eu era
franco luz ao cavaleiro brasileiro pelo
fato de ela chegar em paris
não nasci em frança na china para isso
são duas coisas diferentes
os meus pais são portugueses lutador
contra o regime fascista de salazar no
país ser presa por combater a guerra
colonial e por cantar contra ela e por
isso eu não ache em paris as minhas três
filhas são cardenas na china um milhão
cento e eu sou casado com uma brasileira
é eu sou de certa forma biograficamente
especialista em conexões
estou permanentemente conectado a três
continentes e portanto tem alguma lógica
estar aqui no tek sim que o tema central
é a conexão por outro lado vou falar e o
projeto estabelece é muito ligado isso é
uma questão que preocupa especificamente
que a questão da educação artística é um
estilista dos melhores do mundo chamado
que é nova em santos dizia pra casa numa
toca do telex que fazendo um apanhado de
todos os sistemas de educação do mundo
sem exceção
nós temos em questões de hierarquia e
importância que são dadas as matérias
ministradas desde as crianças até os
jovens
em primeiro lugar as matemáticas
e as ciências é depois humanística e
aqui em baixo as artes e nas artes
nós temos em primeiro lugar as artes
plásticas à literatura à música e lá em
baixo assim bem um só tom a dança o
teatro e eu conto uma história de uma
coreógrafa americana que hoje é
multimilionária por ser curió grafam e
conta uma história que eu queria só
reunir aqui porque de certa forma dar um
enquadramento aquilo que eu vou relatar
essa mulher com a criança foi
diagnosticada um problema sério porque
ela não conseguiu esta queda na altura e
não se inventar da doença e perotti
hiperativa tanto nos podia dizer que era
imperativo porque essa essa neurose anos
assim não tinha sido inventada
ela tinha uma doença muito específica
era criança ela era criança não
conseguir ficar quieta e resolveram levá
la para um cão médico médico teve mora
falar com a mãe e depois pediu à mãe
para sair e diz que seja também deixar a
criança sozinha ligou o rádio ligado o
rádio estava a passar música pediu à mãe
para observar através da janela o
comportamento da filha e imediatamente a
filha começou a dançar eo médico disse a
amanhã sou filha não tem nenhum problema
da doença sua filha é bailarina e a
senhora tem que colocar numa escola da
asa
e assim fez foi para a royal academy of
dancing em londres e transformou se numa
das mais importantes coreógrafos do
mundo e é multimilionário tanto quando
um filho ou uma filha vossa disser que
gosta de dançar fazer teatro pintar
cantar - e convênios aqui há pouco tempo
e larga sarah não dei um fim mas estuda
direito vai fazer um negócio vai fazer
alguma coisa de útil e depois logo se vê
nos seus tempos livros sedãs se duas das
cantas compões pintas ou escreve poesia
como se fosse uma atividade a segunda
área
na verdade aquilo que está a acontecer
por causa do sistema de ensino em todo
mundo é que nós estamos a criar a sogi
que só funciona no pescoço para cima
seja o nosso corpo é uma espécie de
transporte da cabeça porque todo o
sistema de ensino efe forma é que o
corpo para baixo não esteja em
funcionamento em treino em prática
promovendo a criatividade e do corpo
para afastar um órgão muito importante
ter o coração que o grau nas coisas eo
que nos faz acreditar em sonhos e isso é
o que me traz aqui porque este projecto
surgiu eu escrevi esta expressão aqui a
minha mulher disse que ninguém entender
mas fica sempre bem a gente numa
conferência escrever algo que ninguém
vai entender
andaram sempre um ar de intelectuais e
alguma superioridade acadêmica mas eu
vou explicar porque está aqui esta esta
expressão epifania da inevitabilidade
eu treinei bastante para dizer essa
frase engasgar
é num dia 20 de dezembro de 2014
o centro cultural português já organizou
para os pais uma atividade juntamente
com as crianças de duas oficinas que
eram ministrados nas instalações do
centro uma sina do canto e uma oficina
do teatro oficina pequenos chamava-se
pegadinha e oficina de teatro chamada
sucre e organizamos esta apresentação os
pais num espaço público previamente
reservado para o efeito quando chegamos
lá numa sala contígua esse espaço
estavam a colocar um chão de madeira
usando um produto um com cheiro muito
forte uma cola que imediatamente
provocou que as crianças
algumas começaram a sentir mal
foi num sábado à tarde e nós nos
questionamos porque começava da tarde no
junto a uma atividade com crianças já
programado há alguns meses se resolveu
fazer aquela obra naquele momento não
podendo manter atividade no mesmo sítio
nós vamos as crianças e os pais cerca de
150 pessoas para uma biblioteca onde não
cabiam mais de 50 e as crianças
apresentaram os seus trabalhos que
tinham preparado para os pais
no final dessa atuação é eu ea minha
mulher janaína é falando bastante
emocionados com os pais
dissemos que depois deste acontecimento
nós não iríamos descansar enquanto não
fosse capaz de criar um espaço condigno
para que seus filhos pudessem aprender a
cantar aprender a dançar com aprender a
fazer teatro ou outra qualquer forma de
expressão artística foi uma epifania
eu sempre sinto cheiro daquela cola e eu
agradeço a cola porque certa forma foi
graças a cola que a gente descurou os
rabos das cadeiras e passamos a ação ea
inviabilidade exatamente essa é que nós
não podíamos continuar numa cidade que
se diz cultural que ostenta
orgulhosamente o título de capital
cultural fica ver mas que não tem um
único cinema é uma cidade que ostenta
orgulhosamente eu até diria andanças o
flamengo não sei que vocês com todos
eles para inglês o título de cidade
cultural do cavenaghi capital com troca
aveiro e não tinha até à data única
ocupação de crianças pudessem dançar ou
aprender dança é nós fomos testemunhas
durante os processos por exemplo do
grupo de dança ensaiar na rua colocavam
seus telemóveis um 'beco a música e
dançavam na rua e treinavam na rua
vários grupos de dança que hoje em dia
têm a oportunidade de ensaiar no espaço
que entretanto nasceu
e que graças a essa melhoria de
condições graças a essa evolução são os
convidados para dançar nem los angeles
por exemplo nos estados unidos da
américa e que tanto foi hora de dizer
basta como não cor rosa um basta a
sustentar no amor não basta sustentado
na paixão e na crença de acreditar fazer
saímos à procura de um espaço
procuramos a cidade domingo deu vimos
vários galpões abandonados que existem
depois abandonadas em todas as cidades
do cabo verde ou aquelas que são
chamadas cidades e não são um facto mas
existem sempre lugares que estão ali há
espaços vazios prontos para receber em
projectos desta natureza
descobrimos um com o que tinha um dono
de uma empresa privada a uma seguradora
fomos falar com elas apresentamos o
nosso projeto e eles disseram sim
senhora
vocês querem para este espaço é um
espaço muito ângulo do qual nós ocupamos
só uma parte e nós cedemos espaço para
vocês fazerem o vosso projecto mas vocês
vão assinar um documento chamado
cedência precária só um nome feminino
o que é que a cedência precária é um
documento que nós assinamos que a
empresa quiser tomar aquele espaço nós
temos uma semana para pagar na tocha e
ir embora
nós tínhamos duas opções ao fazer a
coisa mesmo assim ou não fazer
resolvemos fazer isso vamos fazer de uma
forma de que fosse cada vez mais
complicado é essa empresa dizer vão se
embora porque nós queremos ocupar o
espaço
e aí entra o gabinete de arquitetura que
ofereceu gratuitamente o espaço o
projeto de arquitetura
isso vocês estão aqui a fazer é o espaço
vazio como estava quando nós vamos pra
lá e no intermédio vocês já estão a ver
crianças que também são alunos das
oficinas que foram criadas depois do
espaço no cheiro
isso foi o que nós encontramos um espaço
que estavam sem utilização há cerca de
20 anos uma antiga fábrica
roupa de camisas em mim deu uma zona que
por sua vez tinha um prédio em
construção
abandonado porque os donos venderam os
andares de iniciar um projeto e depois
fugiram com o dinheiro
uma forma de empreendedorismo e toda
aquela estrutura da fábrica também não
estava terminada
entretanto o prédio desde que ela abriu
conseguiram chegar a acordo com o banco
os proprietários retomou as obras vai
abrir em setembro com possivelmente os
andares mais luxuosos da cidade e o lado
na chegou à escola portuguesa domingo
deu tanto da pensa
formou se uma nova centralidade de uma
zona domingo eu estava completamente ao
abandono e essa nova centralidade foi
com seguida tendo como locomotiva com
força motriz da educação artística como
é que nós fizemos isso foi um verdadeiro
junta mon ao qual se juntou uma pessoa
que nós chamamos nosso padrinho com
muita honra não no sentido cinéfilo do
termo entre o padre um cinéfilo é uma
filosofia mas no sentido de ter sido uma
pessoa chegou à frente
gravou um depoimento antes do projeto
ser realidade
foi o presidente da república e da sara
tavares foi a nossa madrinha
nós fizemos campanhas confundem no
brasil em portugal
em café pessoas como estas quatro em
quatro anos aqui daí foram pessoas que
deram a cara avós gravando depoimentos
para que fosse possível esse espaço não
cheira a gestação durou nove meses não
há nada mais poético de uma gestação que
dura nove meses de gestação 9 - que dá
origem à vida humana e foi curioso que
desde que começaram as obras já em junho
de 2015
até à sua abertura foi em 20 de janeiro
de 2016 direção viciante curiosamente o
aniversário da empresa que cedeu o
espaço
esta é uma fotografia da 1º no primeiro
dia de obras né no espaço
vocês viram no filme eo nascimento nós
fizemos a partir de uma atividade
chamada overdose
ovar 12 na verdade foi maldosa oferta
cultural 12 horas começaram às três da
tarde nas três da manhã
na verdade nós tivemos uma overdose
porque a atividade só terminou às 5 e
tanto foi um momento muito especial para
nós gastar o comprovativo este é
possivelmente um lugar mais importante
do nosso espaço chama-se moral de um
tamanho que tem um nome de toda a gente
que deu alguma colaboração para que este
passo fosse uma realidade
algumas dessas pessoas estão aqui e
muitas vão ver também esta filmagem eu
aproveito aqui para dizer muito obrigado
por fazerem parte deste moral também na
bancada que existe no espaço de
apresentação dos espetáculos nós temos
nomes de pessoas falar o nome por
exemplo do vereador da cultura da cidade
do porto que ofereceu a bancada vai do
porto e que entretanto faleceu
está lá o nome do cursinho fortes nosso
grande poeta que foi o fundador da
empresa que não segue os passos da onu
finalmente da minha mãe isabel alves
costa que tenha a mesma profissão do que
eu era construtora de sonhos e eu
infelizmente não possa por essa
expressão quando preenchem o papel no
aeroporto e está escrito profissão eu
gostaria de colocar o construtor dos
sonhos mas não deixou então e opõe
professor que acho que é o mais parecido
com isso é que uma fotografia da
abertura do qual participou o tamanho
nós crediário que cantou hoje com a sara
tavares e nasceu a alá em que o filho
pela primeira vez nesta minha
intervenção além que quer dizer academia
livro de artes integradas do me deu essa
pintura de vocês vêem ali foi feita por
dois gráficos brasileiros que entretanto
vieram de fortaleza já com espaços
abertos
deram uma oficina de grafite e deixaram
a sua marca
todos os alunos que estão tiveram aulas
naná em pinto uma mão e deixou a sua
marca
todos os alunos que passam o nosso
aniversário então as leis nós colocamos
hoje na parede e deixou a sua marca
ainda um espaço de arte
é de crescimento humano em que você
entra e quando sai o seu bocadinho
humano a sua parcela da atividade ficou
e mantém lá para o futuro as pessoas
poderem testemunhar
tanto a índia cademia que por definição
é um lugar de partilha do conhecimento
livre porque é um espaço de liberdade é
um espaço onde nós ministram as oficinas
de educação artística informais não
ligadas ao sistema de ensino formal e o
a creche dizer graças a deus
de dança do teatro de música dentro da
música percussão com grande mestre mi
clima por exemplo de guitarra de artes
plásticas artes
aqui todas as artes naturalmente
integradas porque nós trabalhamos tendo
como pressuposto um espírito
multidisciplinar e me deu porque nós
acreditamos que está um projeto que dá
voz e reflete aquilo que é a alma da
cidade domingo
este é portanto o nosso movimento hoje é
que os grupos que faziam os seus ensaios
no meio da rua
nos becos função do telemóvel hoje estão
a ensaiar ao i
hoje companhias de teatro que ensaiavam
os terraços das suas casas ou nas salas
de estar naquelas crianças um pouco
maiores para desespero das suas famílias
hoje tem um lugar para ensaiar e um
pouco depois de ter aberto nós temos na
nossa allen oito oficinas permanentes
além daquelas que são pontuais
nós administramos no primeiro
aniversário mil e 700 horas de educação
artística quanto é que isso possa ser
quantificado em termos de negócio mil e
600 horas de educação artística em 1700
horas que crianças jovens e menos jovens
utilizaram o seu tempo para desenvolver
a actividade deste gênio 140 espetáculos
foram ministradas no espaço de um ano
neste local espetáculos e apresentações
sam com grupos que nunca tinham se
apresentado dentro de uma sala de
espetáculos de teatro obviamente a
apresentações de cinema apresentações
música é sempre recebe 15 mil
espectadores já passaram por lá
parece um número muito pequeno mas foi
um ano em algo que há dois anos atrás
não passava de um sonho de motor bia
nós desenvolvemos um trabalho artístico
não me deu há cerca de 25 anos desde
1993 e foi preciso passar em 24 para que
nós possamos dar aulas num lugar que tem
um chão de madeira onde por exemplo uma
criança não corre o perigo de quebrar
uma perna porque o mal e o chão não está
preparado para receber esse tipo de
impacto e eram nesses tipos de solos de
edições de cimento ó terra batida que
eram dadas as aulas provocando muitas
vezes danos irreparáveis às alunas e aos
alunos e esta é é digamos assim nosso
jornal preferido é uma frase de evitar
ou e está aqui não há nada como o sonho
para criar o futuro o tupi hoje carnes
amanhã hoje nós estamos carne de onça
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]